is it worth spending a hundred dollars  more for the microsoft surface compared  to the macbook i'm gonna go ahead and  unplug them and even though everybody's  calling the new macbooks thick boys  check out the surface  [Music]  studio so if you want something that is  insanely loud get this one if you want  something that's still loud but sounds  better the macbook wins apple finally  upgraded to 1080p webcams and here is  microsoft's 1080p webcam let's get into  the displays we have about 3.8 million  pixels compared to 5.9 super unique  hinge you can have it magnetized right  here flat like this let's get into  performance macbooks ssds are three  times faster we have a difference of 70  percent i have lightroom classic open 65  faster with the macbook we are at 17  whereas our m1 pro  56  well i think in my book this is just an  incredible package